les militaires canadiens sont revenus il
ya deux semaines d'afghanistan une étape
qui représente une difficile transition
chez plusieurs chez leurs collègues
américains
le nombre de suicides en témoigne en
compte vingt suicides par jour
malgré tout le congrès tarde à agir et
l'opinion publique semble indifférente
john napier on les appelle les vétérans
du 11 septembre
deux millions et demi de jeunes
américains déployés en irak et en
afghanistan
ils en reviennent mutilé brisé
traumatisé déprimé en colère sans aide
et sans espoir à l'âge de 20 ans le
sergent christopher goldsmith a essayé
de se suicider
et au lieu de l'encadrer l'appareil
militaire l'a traité comme un criminel
dit il un lâche
il a été renvoyé pour mauvaise conduite
une histoire triste certes est la sienne
finit pourtant bien christ feu est sur
la voie de la réhabilitation
on des milliers d'autres vétérans du 11
septembre c'est loin d'être le cas
les suicides dans leurs rangs ont pris
des proportions épidémiques à l'ombre du
congrès une petite cérémonie un appel à
l'aide
les anciens combattants et leurs
familles plantes des drapeaux pour
chaque suicide de soldats en moyenne 22
par jour aux états unis près de huit
mille par an
le département des anciens combattants
est forcément déborder les blessés et
les mutilés sont la priorité la détresse
psychologique et donc négliger adam
renteria on sait quelque chose
il est revenu de la guerre la mort dans
l'âme suicidaire violent et méchant un
organisme privé des deux anciens
combattants lui a donné ce chien rac
hassan son meilleur ami une thérapie peu
répandu peut-être mais qui lui a sauvé
la vie
la cérémonie n'attire que quelques
dizaines de personnes
et rien qu'à senator le public et les
politiques il faut croire n'écoute plus
les drapeaux ont été enlevés la
cérémonie vite oublié mais le problème
reste entier
devant l'indifférence de l'opinion
publique le congrès n'est pas pressés
d'adopter une loi pour aider les
vétérans en détresse pas étonnant alors
que les anciens combattants américains
se sentent abandonnés ici joyce n'a pu
radio-canada washington